ينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك معنا
مساء الخير
اجوفستيل ماريوبل مناطق نذكر تماما كيف
تمت السيطره عليها من قبل روسيا لماذا
تستهدفها برايك الان اوكرانيا
عبد السلام الاستهداف البعيد يجب ان يكون
هناك هدف معين او هدف زاد قيمه عاليه
استراتيجيه اذا اعتبرنا ماريو بول هي بين
الدومباز وبين شبه جزيره القرم وضمن قد
تكون وهذا تحليل وليس معلومه قد يكون هناك
هدف معين ممكن ان يكون له علاقه
باللوجستيه ولكن يجب ان نسال ايضا من وجهه
اخرى ما هو السلاح الذي استهدف هذه
المنطقه على المسافات بعيده هل هو الستور
مشادو الكروز الانجليزي
الذي يبلغ مداه ما يقارب 250 كيلومتر هذه
امور معينه بدانا نراها كمؤشرات
عميد الياس عندما تقول اوكرانيا انها
بحاجه الى نحو 48 طائره اف 16
لتحرير المناطق التي سيطرت عليها روسيا هل
هذا العدد كاف كيف تنظر لهذا العدد وما
امكانيه تامينه ومن اين
48 طائره مقابل 900 او الف طائره روسيه
اغلبها من الجيل الرابع ومنها من الجيل
الخامس هذا الامر ليس متوازن في شكل ما
بالاضافه الى تحضير الهجوم البري وبالتالي
48 طائره على سبيل المثال فدا
عامل الصيانه كي يحسن عمله ويصبح يعني
تقريبا خبير في هذا الامر يستلزم مئه
وثلاثه ولا ثلاثين يوما تدريب والسنه
كما يقال العمل عليها كي يصبح اثنين
الطيار الذي يريد قياده هذه الطائره ان
يطير في هذه الطائره شيء
ان يدعم العمليات البريه شيء ان يقاتل في
الجو شيء حتى ان يطير من ضمن شرب من
طائرتين ثلاث او اربعه هذه امور معقده
وتتطلب وقتا كثيرا قد تكون هذه الطائرات
لمرحله ما بعد وقف العمليات الحربيه
لحمايه اوكرانيا من اي هجوم مستقبلي ولكن
48 بالتاكيد لن تكون كافيه
اين يمكن ان تتحرك قوات فاجنر في المرحله
المقبله طالما انه انهى المهمه في باخمت
عبد السلام وصلت الى
نقطه بعد ان قيل انه قتل منها ما يقارب
العشرين الف وهذا باعتراف الممول
البريجوجين فاذا هي في مرحله الانكفاء
تسليم الجيش الروسي بخموت على بالحد
الاقصى ولكن هذا الامر التسليم يتطلب هو
عمليه معقده بحد ذاتها الانسحاب هو كما
يقال وقفه عملانيه اوبريشن البوز لاعاده
التكوين للتدريب والاستراحه وانا اعتقد
اليوم هي ستكون احتياط لاي هجوم معين من
اوكرانيا في اي مكان ما وانا اعتقد ايضا
ستكون مهمتها اكثر بالاتجاه الافريقي او
اتجاه خارج اوكرانيا طيب اشرت الى
الانسحاب من بخموت يعني ما سهوله الانسحاب
من منطقه
كباخموت ما هي العقبات التي يمكن ان تقف
دون ذلك بالنسبه لقوات فاغنر
فداء الانسحاب لفاقنر يجب ان يكون هناك
قوات بديله هذه القوات البديله القادمه هي
جديده ليس لها وعي الزمان والمكان وليس
لها التجربه بعد اكثر من عشره اشهر في هذه
المنطقه والتسلم والتسليم لا يمكن يعني لا
يمكن ان يكون بين ليله وضحاها يعرض القوات
الحديثه الى هجمات رديه من قبل الاخوه
القوات الاوكرانيه هذا بالاضافه الى ماذا
سيفعل بالمخزون من السلاح ومن الزخير التي
لديه فاجنر وما هي العلاقه اصلا المتوتره
بين القوات الروسيه التقليديه
وفاجنر فاذا هذا الامر يتطلب تنظيف المكان
الزخائر تامين المكان وهذا ما يسمى بالامن
العماني وهذي من اعقد الخطط العسكريه
شكرا لكم العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي كان معنا من بيروت شكرا لك